well some parents this morning and
students are reporting chaotic
conditions in Los Angeles schools as a
teacher strike enters its second day
educators in the nation's second largest
school district stood in pouring rain on
the picket lines yesterday the district
says fewer than one hundred and forty
two thousand students showed up for
class that's about a quarter of the
district's 600,000 students Tony de
copal is outside San Fernando Senior
High School north of downtown Los
Angeles Tony good morning a good morning
while there's more rain expected today
and also more picketing as those
teachers demand greater resources for a
predominantly low-income school district
that they fear is falling behind but in
the meantime as you point out not a lot
of learning is going on attendance down
across the district and at this school
in particular attendance was down 90% on
Monday armed with ponchos and picket
signs tens of thousands of Los Angeles
public school teachers took their fight
to the streets Monday we are willing to
do what it takes for our children for
our students so we have to be out here
in the rain that's what we're going to
do we're going to be in the rain it's
not fair for teachers to buy supplies
for their students
Claudia Aguilera has a daughter in the
fourth grade what brings you out to the
picket line I'm fighting for her to have
a small class along with smaller class
sizes teachers are demanding higher pay
and more funding for counselors and
nurses they've been working without a
contract for a year and a half we're
doing everything that we can to help
these kids and I don't think the
district is doing everything they can to
help us to help the kids while the
district is keeping schools open it
wants Union teachers back at work we
urge them to resume bargaining with us
anytime anywhere 24/7 we'd like to
resolve this with 80 percent of students
in the district coming from low-income
families many kids rely on school not
just for education but for daily meals
supper was served at Atwater Avenue
Elementary on Monday but attendance was
down by almost two-thirds the kids who
did show up say they spent the day
reading books and doing puzzles it's
been weird because all the classes were
mixed and
sixth grade fifth grade and fourth grade
my canvas was like wow we really can't
live without teachers I think a lot of
people agree with little Gisele there we
mentioned this is a low-income school
district but there's another factor here
the UCLA Civil Rights Project points out
that this district is one of the most
segregated in the country more than 70%
Latino less than 10% white students the
longer this strike drags on the more
people here will wonder if those numbers
were reversed with the money be easier
to find Norah
it's a good point Tony thank you and you
think about how many kids rely on school
to get a meal the superintendent of the
LA Unified School District is writing in
The Wall Street Journal today that 82%
of students rely on free or reduced wage
meals at school including 72,000 special
needs students this is an emergency